i need to know
because um well i was born the year
after
we landed a man on the moon but uh
what good does getting back to the moon
do
us i'm i'm just i'm curious and then
now i'm putting on my ignorant hat so
but just
walk me through why we need to go back
to the moon yeah
so a handful of reasons uh number one
the engineering science and basic
research
support to go to the moon and build out
a moon colony perhaps even
i think can be inspiring exciting
energizing
and um enabling of a whole
stem revitalization in the education
infrastructure so i think there's some
value there
oh that's definitely you you had me you
had me at revitalizing education you can
stop there that's so amazing sorry
continue
but as a wayward point so to say
on your way to mars or further i do
believe
that the moon can prove useful as a
refueling of whatever
station you want to call it so you know
this is now longer range thinking i
think that's why i put in the prediction
that
they announced plans to build the colony
not that they built the colony by then
in the next five years um and so i think
that's coming
it may enable us to use some really cool
3d printing technology
and build structures on the moon etc so
there's some really interesting options
there
further there are materials on the moon
we know the moon has
helium-3 which can be a fuel source for
fusion
um we know the chinese have gone there
with the idea of maybe taking some of
this stuff from bringing it back home
okay so there may be some physical
commodity materials
uh logic to going to the moon as well
and so there's the scientific endeavor
there's the energizing and inspiring of
educational endeavor
uh there's the sort of future jumping
point logic
and what i would say as was the case
with a lot of our military innovations
through
and the military research through the
cold war there will be
a lot of unintended benefits right
whether it's
you know in the cold war communication
mechanisms generated something called
the internet
um you know we don't know what's gonna
come
we don't know what's gonna come or how
but the odds are in favor that there
will be spillover positive impacts
um now i know where to send
all four of my children who by the way
have been forced since they were five
years old to learn mandarin
they still don't quite they're starting
to understand they're starting to get it
as they age
um start it wasn't
coveted as much as it was the trade war
that started to re-jigger the way
we view the supply chain yeah now
i've been hearing rumblings from my
friends uh
who are our big china watchers that we
might see a
second lunar new year in a in a row
effectively cancelled yeah because
the virus is not in muhan province the
virus the virus is right outside beijing
yeah uh and so i mean again these these
are just things that i'm hearing
but i don't know that if you're ford or
if you're a major manufacturer and
you've been dealing with input prices
on a roller coaster i cannot imagine
another major disruption in the global
supply chain
uh i mean just but one example 24 of all
auto supplies come from china into the
united states
people don't realize how how integ
it's not like flipping a switch and
saying we're just going to move
everything to mexico or vietnam
it's it's not that easy but you see
this causing an evolution in the way
we we approach inventories yeah
yeah so a couple of things i'll say
there in terms of the dynamic
danielle first of all the global supply
chain logic
that accompanied globalization was
driven by a
lowest cost just-in-time logic
it was based on a handful of arbitrages
generally economic arbitrages that took
place
over the last 40 years right so you went
to where the labor was cheapest
by the way that logic doesn't matter as
much when you use technology
you went to where the taxes on value
added were cheapest
by the way in light of lower corporate
taxes in america that logic doesn't
matter as much
you went to where energy supplies were
consistent and you could have some
reasonable structure on your cost side
of things from an energy input
by the way north america now has pretty
stable resilient
regular supplies of energy at reasonable
costs so
that arbitrage went away you went to
where
uh you know transportation costs didn't
matter because
there was this frictionless world well
that sort of we had some more frictions
put into play so
when you throw all of this into the mix
first it was the trade war you say okay
this little widget that went into my
final product
sweet i thought it was six dollars wait
daniel you're telling me now after this
tariff it's gonna be 22
my business model just went out the
window i can't do that all right so all
right let me move it out of there for
that
oh wait now you're telling me hold on
that six dollar widget which i was
willing to pay twenty dollars for
because i had to change my business
model
now you're telling me i can't even get
it what because there's lockdowns
okay that's not acceptable now you're
rippling through my whole business so
that doesn't work
now you're telling me there's
geostrategic reasons of my great power
rival
is gonna potentially have access to my
supply chain and the intellectual
property and stuff that's produced there
i don't like the sound of that okay now
let's rip it out of there oh by the way
then there's this esg
dynamic that says oh you want a smaller
carbon footprint for your supply chain
well a long supply chain has more carbon
being utilized in a shorter one
so okay that's another pressure point
anyway you can add these up there are
multiple pressure points that make me
believe the geography of manufacturing
is shifting and it's going to move
closer to end consumers
so producers and consumers which were
distanced in space and time
are going to move closer and they're
going to move closer and so the idea of
just-in-time lowest cost supply chain
logic
is giving way to just in case resilient
supply chain logic
and that means part of resilience is
higher buffers
greater inventories to handle potential
disruptions
and i think it's best captured with just
in time
moving to just in case i like that i
like that a lot and it sounds like it's
probably promising for
mexico's and canada's economy well i
mean by extension
yeah i think it's a regionalization it's
not a
ending of globalization it's a
shortening of supply chains it's a
regionalization logic
um you know because labor still matters
it's just not as important such that i'm
willing to oversee
or take inordinate risks to take my
supply chain halfway around the world
uh in the middle of a uh pandemic
all these other dynamics yeah